foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
did with the live [__] I would be
[__] dead in the water the live one's
an interesting choice because Louie did
a similar thing Louie did it live on his
website and then he's gonna release a
full edited version of the set and then
I guess that's exactly what Chris is
doing he released it in the full edit
the [__] about Will Smith was root yes
yeah
ruthless it's just like imagine the you
know in life you play chess you move
pieces around you say I do this and the
counter would be that and like imagine
the thought like I'm just gonna slap
Chris Rock one of the greatest stand-up
comedians of all time it's not like he's
gonna tear my very vulnerable life apart
with some of the best comedy that
anybody's ever written and he's gonna
hone it over a year before he releases
it yeah like what a terrible
unprovoked attack
what a dumb thing to do to do to like be
that person who's like publicly loved
you know like Will Smith was until that
moment I mean until that moment nobody
really had a bad thing to say about
maybe didn't like one movie or maybe you
thought the superhero movie was dumb or
but everybody loved that guy everybody
loves it I loved will I love will I
still love will a year later you can't
tell somebody when is the right time to
cut back it's unfair yeah I mean you've
been on tour with them yeah a lot of
people thought that he seemed very upset
and angry So Over The Slap
okay people can we be honest right now a
lot of people think he was upset he was
Furious yeah I could have ended that
could have ended so many different ways
and I'm gonna tell you who was more
upset than Chris his family he had
people in his family want to retaliate
against Will Smith Will Smith when he
did that he put his family at risk he
put his family at risk he put his kids
at risk so if you can't take a joke if
somebody could take a smack you could
take a joke I loved it live he cheated
at the seller and he wasn't selling it
so much you know not at all the water
bottle look at this bottle of water he's
gonna make it happen I was like all
right we got it man I don't want to [__]
on another comic but like he's you know
he's one of the greats but
seeing it live at The Cellar it was a
little more tone day it was just about
the material and it I liked it more well
I think also with someone like Chris
Rock there's a bit of the Jerry Seinfeld
thing where it's like when you become
when you're so iconic your Cadence
becomes like a joke a little bit right
when Seinfeld says like what's the deal
yeah like it just it feels like funny
almost you know sure sure when Chris
Rock there's a few times where he was
like he was like the girl like I don't
know whatever he was saying like you
know a girl's [__] changes the world
changes though what her world yeah like
the way he was he didn't like what he
was calling me so much he goes a [__]
he's a [__] I kept saying it and every
time he could be like is um this is Will
Smith yeah I think he kept calling him a
[__] and he was like every time it was
like a little angrier yeah that was a
suck though that he flubbed that joke at
the end oh that was the worst and he
probably did that like 20 times leading
up to it and didn't I know you know he
probably like did that perfectly so many
times and then that stressed me out and
then I know and then I honestly was
watching I go wait what just happened
like for a second I was like the live
thing is a horrible idea I was thinking
I'm like is he gonna try to do it again
like yeah that's it and he did yeah he
did yeah I know well I guess there I
heard they're gonna what they're gonna
cut it up and that's what I thought I
heard that too yeah that's what I was
kind of thinking I was like this but how
great would it be to be Will Smith like
oh you got me except for that flow you
can just Zing him to go live in front of
millions of [__] in Netflix
which is the giant you're like going oh
[__] it's it's it's a new nervousness
yeah he's been doing this [__] for 30
some maybe 40 years it's a new nervous
and he's a technician he's a technician
and it's not like a free-form kind of no
and I've seen him work [__] over and
over and he records two or three times
and gets the best out of that yeah and
that's what most people do most people
and there's nothing wrong with he tried
the live one hey man you got the power
to do that [__] so next minute he might
do it for me helicopter I don't [__]
know
what's up y'all you know but he I think
it I think it would have been a little
bit different stronger if he recorded it
but I think so too we got what we got
yeah and people are discussing it
because everybody wants to know talk
about that [__] slap because I
know he started to talk about it on some
of his live show with Chappelle yeah he
was bringing it up here again because
everyone's like what about this slap
he's gonna say something yeah it's so
it's so hard it's hard it's so hard to
build a stand-up special when you know
everyone in the room all wants but it's
hard you just got slapped yeah yeah how
the [__] do you talk about that [__]
that's tough you got smacked in front of
everybody around the world and Will
Smith smacked you which was so [__]
wrong of will I'm sorry and I think
Chris Rock has every right to be mad for
as long as he [__] wants to who does
will is embarrassing hurt by what Chris
said about him and his family and his
neck like special he didn't watch it but
he had people tell him what Chris said
it's everywhere when you look online and
on social media so Will and Jada have
seen comments about it it's so
ridiculous you just can't say anything
like if you're Will Smith you gotta just
take this one I'd be like what do you
like it's the same way I'm saying Chris
Rock can't really call him a [__]
because he got bitched out it's like
Will Smith can't really be like yeah man
that's too far dude you went over the
line
it's gonna be all over the place now
dude everyone's gonna see it to be like
you had to be like uh I'm hurt and
embarrassed by what you said hey because
yeah that joke was a real slap in the
face
to your point about live I would never
do a live stand up yeah I guess my
feeling with the live stand-up thing is
that like it doesn't
I understand creating a a gimmick for
someone to watch your special I think
that that makes sense that's marketing
and that's smart if he didn't have the
Will Smith thing do it live because now
you have a gimmick people go well I just
want to see what could happen if he does
it live right I don't like Live Well
just just just just take this in
um but he already had a hook
so don't add more pressure on the moment
yeah just record four shows to use the
best show cut them together do whatever
you want do it nobody's watching it to
see if you're gonna get the words right
or not we want to watch you deliver your
best performance and they've censored
that the Chris Rock special which I
thought was really did you see this I I
didn't I saw clips of it they censored
it well apparently they pulled out the
Will Smith thing or something wait what
no that's the only reason why anybody
watched it I know isn't that true though
didn't they do this
I saw it like clips of it from Netflix
I just read an article that said
something this morning uh they said that
they're going to remove it maybe or
something I could be wrong I highly
doubt that no but I think it would Chris
not Netflix look at let me see let's see
I you just have to cut this out I doubt
that Chris Rock removes Will Smith joke
from special oh wow can they do that
after the fact on Netflix I mean sure
they can do whatever they want on
Netflix but Chris Rock's fumbled Will
Smith removed from Netflix special it's
every article I can read Chris Rock's
Netflix show the Will Smith joke will be
removed LA Times all this fumbled Will
Smith joke I probably didn't if you
watch the original he does stumble he
[__] up the joke if you watch the
original he I don't know what he said
he's he he uh concussion when he gets to
the word concussion he like tells a
piece of it incorrectly and he talks
about saying it wrong he's like I [__]
that up but then he continues on
um but it's only one line it's a little
sliver yeah it's a little tiny sliver of
a thing that okay so because they're not
pulling out the no no no no no no no but
they're removing the piece which is
strange because it's like why'd you put
it in the first place you had Final Cut
you I watched mine a thousand times yeah
I watched it so many times you hate
every single SEC you hate the way your
stupid face looks you know you're like
look at my teeth you know like you start
to like pick yourself to shreds you're
like way to go you fat dad like
everything looks sad when you keep
watching it so I there's no way he
didn't see that a hundred times and
think about it which is weird that he
put it out because it's like well it was
live
I gotta watch Chris Rock's new special
he did it live and I heard nothing but
rave reviews from every comic
that I love so I gotta check that out
it's on Netflix now streaming now he did
it live which I think is [__] the
balls that that takes and then also you
know what's amazing about that no
editing it's over
you do it it's done there you go
you don't have to do that awful thing
where you hey now we're gonna sit down
and watch an hour and 10 minutes of you
I'm sure you're making good decisions no
you should you should look at it no no
no we want we're very PR no it's good
it's good you should sit down I don't
want to watch it no but you have to
have to you
have anyways and it's always great for
stand up one of the greatest of all time
comes out and puts a [__] giant
special out there that everybody [__]
loves that so that's oh that's good for
everybody
it's good for everybody you opened in
Baltimore you were there that night I
was there during his live show on
Saturday night and I'm proud of you
buddy I saw you on TMZ I agreed with
everything you said and I was all and
I'm angry and concerned about comedy
today because of listen he was brilliant
I think he did I agree with you
everything that he needed to do but are
you surprised by even a little bit of
blowback he's getting no because I've
been around long enough and seen Comics
rise in their profile where they go
beyond the comedy conversation into the
cultural conversation and anybody who's
doing really well people will latch
their cause onto it but don't you think
that happens more now than it ever did
it seems like it I mean maybe I just
didn't know big Comics 30 years ago but
now I'm like oh okay if you're getting
killed on social media or it's probably
because you're killing it you're
crushing it it's like it's like but
Chris was like at the epicenter that I
believe that what happened to Chris with
Will is the reason that that guy uh
made it okay for himself to jump on
stage to Chappelle at the Hollywood Bowl
I don't know what happened to will look
like he was enjoying the joke
right even
he went on the ass left
and then Jada rolled her eyes a little
bit of head like you [__] and he went
yeah that [__] ain't funny
the thing that overwhelms me is as
somebody who just shot a a one-hour
stand-up special with probably
two percent of the budget that Chris
Rock spent I was overwhelmed by the
production value all the pre-show stuff
the staging the backstage the lighting
the amount of cameras even his outfit
like everything was just so [__]
First Rate it was almost intimidating it
was like all right just do the [__]
comedy but uh you know I think you know
the criticism some people have of Chris
Rock is that he does that preacher thing
where he keeps teeing up the premise
over and over again like a chorus I
don't mind that because it's it's his
rhythm it's he's got there's something
very awkward about Chris Rock that I
find endearing there's something very
genuine about how awkward he is he's not
Chappelle he's not a natural smooth
comedian he's just he's sort of just
like a guy who's finding his way uh like
me in that last sentence and um so but
but I think there was a lot of strong
stuff I thought it's the the stuff about
Will Smith was ballsy [__] yeah but I
thought it was really strong yeah he has
a consistent Rhythm and that rhythm is
awkward that rhythm is sometimes or most
of the time not smooth you know like but
then you know a lot of the times it's
like that little footwork when you're
going up to kick the ball and then but
he lands that punch line you know
exactly he has that Rhythm and he knows
where he's Landing it you know what I
mean and that's Flawless when he lands
it and I've noticed his audience is
getting Blacker
or they're choosing to shoot more black
members of the audience he used to be a
he used to be a real crossover comic and
most of his audience was white it's
crazy as a comedian
who's done this for like a while now
when you realize that all the best
comedians are over 50. you're like oh
you can just keep getting better if you
work at it yeah and I think it's his
best set in 20 years yes of all the
stuff that I think is his best and he
was on
fire yeah and for like an hour 40 on
fire I mean the he kept it up the pace I
was like his energy was crazy there were
so many great takes so many high high
level bits
and he would you know he was just exact
for me exactly what I want to see just
statement provocative you're like
where's this going to go and then just
loaded with jokes his take on the slap
was [__] so good and so much better
than
you know then I would have said or
imagined it's so much you could tell he
took his time with it because it's so
thoughtful it's like a thoughtful
hilarious and he dresses him down in the
in a way that you're like
mm-hmm
[Music]